inversión y acciones concretas eso es lo
que se espera de este foro sobre
igualdad de género sobre todo que la
situación es apremiante tras un año y
medio de pandemia que hoy 19 que ha
afectado en su mayoría a las mujeres 47
millones de ellas están en extrema
pobreza y además la violencia doméstica
ha aumentado aquí en el cabo de lugo el
presidente manuel mccomb participó en la
ceremonia de apertura acompañado de
varios dirigentes del mundo algunos de
ellos participaron de manera virtual
pero ya desde eeuu se hicieron varios
anuncios contundentes
por una parte francia que aumenta su
contribución a la educación de las niñas
en el mundo también hay un aumento en la
contribución para el emprendimiento de
las mujeres la creación de empresas eeuu
que prometió 12 mil millones de dólares
por los próximos cinco años hay una
creación de una coalición de países
entre ellos argentina y francia para la
distribución gratuita de métodos
anticonceptivos en los países en
desarrollo y por último la creación de
un fondo económico para apoyar a las
organizaciones feministas se espera que
al término de estos tres días de
conversatorios pues haya una nueva hoja
de ruta
para acelerar el progreso en esta
igualdad entre hombres y mujeres y sobre
todo que ese progreso sea duradero